live from here this is the show and a
wonderful show you travel the country
you talk to random people what have you
learned from the people that you've met
out in America is the name of the
segment that I do and I go out in
America and I find that people are doing
pretty great and but they feel like
losers everybody feels like they're not
doing enough you're doing enough this is
what a life is a simple life is a
beautiful thing
people are going on social media and
they're getting depressed because
they're seeing people live these amazing
lives no first of all no one's living an
amazing life no one they're posting the
best shots they've got right oh this is
us in Paris yeah you don't see them like
50 hours sitting there at baggage claim
they're not putting closer to that this
is my wife having diarrhea after eating
a French tart highlights really don't
get depressed get even if your friend is
douchey enough to post 50 pictures of
their Hawaiian vacation start posting
pictures of you at their house he just
peed in the pool
I'm sorry about the screen you couldn't
find the key yeah I want to change these
sheets when you get back she say this is
what happened with the with the simpler
things yes this is what a life is you
see people with money and fame you're
like what and I like that right what's
wrong with me no this is a life this is
so much but you don't want that that's a
hassle this is what a life is you run
out of toothpaste you need more
toothpaste tell yourself that for a week
and a half you're stomping on it's
squeezing it's pushing through the hole
from the inside trying to get one strand
on your brush so don't feel like a
monster at the office when you finally
get your ass to CVS and get a new thing
of tooth that you come home slide that
fresh tube out of that long box you feel
like you did something don't you yeah
[Applause]
you